[Musica]
se vuoi lavorare nel mondo dello
spettacolo deve dimagrire non troverai
mai un fidanzato con questo fisico
signora la bambina ingrassa forse il
caso di mettere la dieta bene dopo
questo viaggio a ritroso vi mostro una
foto di me da piccolina poi vedete una
bambina grassa io oggi no dico oggi
perché ci ho impiegato diversi anni
della mia vita prima di iniziare ad
ascoltare la mia voce il rapporto con il
mio corpo è cambiato parecchio nel corso
della mia vita e anche cambiata la
percezione di che cosa sia
effettivamente un corpo grasso a fine
anni 90 quando sono nata io e inizio
anni 2000 venivi considerata grassa si
portavi da una 42 in su oggi dai ce la
caviamo fra una 46 una 48 per poi salire
d'italia io da piccola sono sempre stata
considerata grassa dalle elementari fino
ai primi anni del liceo non ho fatto
altro che ricevere giudizi da parte dei
miei compagni di scuola i tipici
bulletti che per accaparrarsi un posto
nel club gestito dai più cool della
classe erano pronti a fare di tutto
anche farti sentire uno schifo i
commenti però arrivarono anche da parte
degli adulti furono anche quelli che mi
insegnarono di più ad esempio quando il
mio maestro di italiano mi disse davanti
a tutta la classe muri che aumentato un
po la pancia forse il caso di mettersi a
dieta avevo 9 anni
9 è pure quando a 7 anni cui operare
d'urgenza per via di un tumore benigno
alla tibia sinistra e ci vollero quattro
sedute dal pediatra prima che lui mi
prescrisse una radiografia diceva che se
zoppi cavo era per colpa del mio peso mi
hanno ripetuto talmente tante volte che
l'ho grassa che ho iniziato a crederci e
anche se lo fossi stata perché questo
aggettivo deve essere sempre connotato
in maniera negativa anche quando non
viene diagnosticato nessun problema di
salute grasso un grasso è un aggettivo
ma un insulto di conseguenza mio peso ha
iniziato ad oscillare ho iniziato a
soffrire di binge eating disorder
della alimentazione incontrollata anche
in seguito alla morte di mio papà quando
avevo 8 anni il cibo era diventato il
mio rifugio il periodo fra le medie
liceo fu un incubo perché ormai erano le
paranoie a governare i miei pensieri
infatti mi preclude vo tantissime
esperienze perché mio unico scopo era
nascondere il mio grasso quindi felpone
digiuni non andavo al mare seguivo
quelle diete della serie perderai sette
chili in cinque giorni
e così via non ero felice ma facciamo un
salto nel 2019 arriva la svolta deciso
di partecipare alla body positiv network
una sfilata in intimo in piazza duomo a
milano
letteralmente davanti al duomo facevo
ancora molta fatica a mostrarmi
figuriamoci in una delle piazze più
famose d'italia infatti mi ricordo che
io non volevo accettare
assolutamente no ma avevo una voce
dentro la mia testa che mi diceva di
farlo come se fosse arrivato il mio
momento di uscire dalla comfort zone di
sfidare me stessa avevo un sentore che
questa poteva essere la cosa che mi
avrebbe cambiato la vita
e infatti fu così successivamente alla
sfilata michelle sy in un pianto
liberatorio perché finalmente avevo
capito che anch'io avevo le stesse
opportunità e possibilità di tutti a
prescindere dal mio fisico che anch'io
merita un rispetto che anche il mio
corpo era valido avevo proprio cambiato
il modo di vedermi e di vivermi ho
iniziato ad avere un dialogo costruttivo
con il mio corpo e non più distruttivo
era cambiata proprio la visione che
avevo di me stessa come se fino a quel
momento fosse sempre stato lo specchio
decidere come mostrare la mia immagine
riflessa non era cambiata la forma ma la
consapevolezza ci tenevo raccontarvi in
breve questo capitolo della mia vita per
introdurmi un argomento che mi sta molto
a cuore la boa di positività la body
positivi di nasce circa undici anni fa
per merito di donne grasse nere e quali
decisero di iniziare a condividere
questo hashtag hashtag body positivity
con lo scopo di normalizzare i corpi non
conformi per definizione dice che ogni
corpo merita di esistere senza essere
discriminato non significa chiamarsi
dovrebbe diventare obbligatorio anche
perché questo innescherebbe un
meccanismo secondo cui non siamo più
legittimati a sentirci come vogliamo nei
confronti del nostro corpo ed è anche
importante non vederla come un trend
perché qui si sta parlando le vite di
persone reali che non sono di passaggio
come una moda infatti secondo me il vero
cambiamento avverrà nel momento in cui
la diversità non verrà più sfruttata
come strumento di marketing ma come arma
di rappresentanza in più la body
positivi che non ha a che fare né con
l'estetica né con la salute è un
movimento di rivendicazione per corpi
non conformi lo dico per la tua salute
non è vero la maggior parte delle volte
che riceviamo critiche del genere nei
confronti del nostro corpo è
esclusivamente per una questione di
estetica perché ci hanno sempre fatto
credere che esista un corpo perfetto a
cui ambire e aspirare anche perché che
qualifica aveva miei insegnanti di
italiano per dirmi che dovevo mettermi a
dieta se vogliamo parlare di salute
allora dobbiamo farlo con le dovute
maniere l'area giusto peso alle parole e
soprattutto avere le competenze per
poterlo fare il mio peso non determina
né il mio stato di salute né il
trattamento da riservarsi basato sul mio
aspetto anch'io vorrei avere la
confidence come hai fatto questa la
domanda che mi ha fatto molto riflettere
ultimamente perché ancora oggi vedere un
corpo non conforme a indossare abiti che
magari lo mostrano viene visto come un
atto di coraggio quando invece dovrebbe
essere la norma
e arrivato il momento di cambiare questa
visione anche perché io non ho avuto
coraggio
io non ero alla ricerca di un autostima
io volevo semplicemente essere serena
volevo smetterla di precludermi
esperienze e di soffrire per via del mio
corpo è importante secondo me fare una
distinzione che per quanto sottile
considero fondamento quella fra
rappresentanza e ideale ogni epoca ha i
suoi ideali di corpo a cui ambire con le
sue rispettive icone queste icone
associate al persuasivo racconto dei
mass media ci fanno credere che sia
normale avere un certo tipo di corpo
nascondendo abilmente tutti i vari
sforzi che ci vogliono per ottenere
questi irreali risultati il capitalismo
sopravvive perché crea degli standard
poor bianchi e per magia il mercato una
soluzione a tutti i nostri problemi che
si parli di abiti o di programmi
dimagranti tutto ciò viene confezionato
alla perfezione per farci vendere un
prodotto in poche parole non è reale
quello che è reale invece la moltitudine
le infinite sfaccettature che un corpo
assume la sua forma la sua storia le sue
cicatrici sto cambiamento e per questo
dovremo chiedergli scusa per tutte le
volte che lo abbiamo odiato e perdonare
noi stessi per averlo fatto è questo che
ci rende potenti è questo che ci fa
trovare una pace con noi stessi o almeno
per me è stato così tutto questo per
dirvi che il mio percorso mi ha fatto
realizzare che non è mai stato il
cambiamento nel mio corpo rendermi
felice ma la percezione senza
condizionamenti esterni che io ho di
esso per concludere è solamente una la
domanda da fare a chiedermi solo se sono
felice